il aura du retard si tu peux tu es un
mécréant américains ou européens
un australien ou un canadien t-il eu
comme tu peux
il peint que bell où tu fais tes bagages
ou tu prépares des explosifs
il n'a pas d'explosifs de munitions
fonce sur lui avec une voiture
précipiterait dans le vide
punchy achètes ton billet d'avion ou qui
aiguise son couteau c'est une manne
aspirer à une menace qui clôt balles ce
qui aura d'autres attentats au canada
ben oui après des mois parce que dans
polisse et nos agents de renseignement
peut pas être partout tant cette
impossibilité le canada et d'un ami
savons hills
ceci est un message pour le canada nous
arrivons et nous vous détruirons
contré le terrorisme islamiste
l'obsession de l'occident depuis
l'attaqué du world trade center le
canada n'y échappe pas un premier
complot terroriste connu sous le nom des
18 de toronto ait déjoué en 2006 il
avait suffisamment d'explosifs pour
faire des dommages importants selon la
démonstration de la gers
2014 le terrorisme islamiste fait ses
premières victimes au pays un des deux
militaires renversé hier par la voiture
de martin rondeau à saint jean sur
richelieu est mort mais avant d'être
abattu le forcené avait d'abord pris
pour cible le caporal n'étonne série law
deux morts deux soldats les canadiens
découvrent qu'ils ne sont pas à l'abri
d'autres attentats auront lieu les goûts
quand comment débusquer les terroristes
prêts à passer à la à quel point
devons-nous nous inquiéter plus on en
apprend sur cet attentat terroriste
déjoué hier plus on réalise à quel point
on l'a échappé belle
le suspect brûlé monter dans un taxi
avec deux bombes
le dise ou dernier le kamikaze à wind
river s'apprête à commettre le troisième
attentat en sol canadien
quand il est tué par un agent de la grc
le père darwin ne blâme qu'une seule
personne
son fils choisi le chemin qu'il a choisi
je ne blâme pas la grc d'avoir mis fin à
ses jours a été dans la mire des
autorités canadiennes pendant 18 mois
mais le dise ou 2016 alors qu'il
s'apprête à tuer des innocents
il n'est plus considéré comme une
priorité amarna thomas racing and a
connue à eindhoven pour ce chercheur
universitaire en radicalisation violente
il y a des leçons à tirer de son
histoire parce qu'elle contient tous les
éléments qui inquiète les autorités
ce n'est pas comme certaines attaques en
europe où les individus sortent de nulle
part et rennes étaient connus et
surveillés ou harouna abdou rahmane
un de ces pseudo né musulman est né à
regina dans une famille de militaires
il a une enfance difficile sa mère meurt
d'un cancer au cerveau
il n'a que 7 ans c'était consternant
il était en colère contre la terre
entière il m'accusait d'avoir tué sa
mère à un moment donné il a cessé de
manger
il voulait la rejoindre un jour m'a dit
je voudrais que ce soit toi plutôt calme
il n'avait que 7 ans et demi c'était
déchirant aucun père ne voudrait
entendre cela abandonnent l'école et
travers son adolescence dans la drogue
et l'alcool
un an avant de mourir il est connu des
autorités et parle ouvertement de sa
radicalisation à la radio du cbi si il
confie qu'il a d'abord découvert l'islam
à 17 ans lorsque sa copine est tombé en
scène à 20 explique que le point
tournant de sa radicalisation serait la
mort de son bébé à sa naissance un
moment énorme et tatum
après
il à partir de ce moment à rennes
doivent eux affiche ouvertement ses
idées de plus en plus radicale à 20 ans
il rêve d'un califat il s'affiche comme
un membre de dèche
au canada le groupe armé état islamique
et condamne le gouvernement canadien
pour son implication en irak comme il
explique en entrevue
zerbib aux écoutes sur rouleaux sont
pour lui des héros
dans cette entrevue fait un en avant de
mourir il affirme qu'il n'a pas
l'intention de commettre un attentat
mais il admire ce qu'ils font et se
passionne pour les combattants de dèche
l'ontarien john maguire a rejoint les
rangs de l'état islamique en 2013
doivent eux partagent la vidéo de john
maguire sur internet
un geste qui ne passe pas inaperçu un
officier du scrs leur encontre
quelques temps après dans un café de
winnipeg à partir de ce moment hayward
sera dans la mire des autorités
combien d'individus sont connus des
services de renseignement pour leur
radicalisation islamique
après plusieurs mois de négociations le
scrs accorde à enquête sa première
entrevue depuis 2010 je peux pas vous
donner de chiffres et de toute façon des
chefs chance sur une base quotidienne
mais est-ce que c'est des dizaines des
centaines des milliers
je voudrais que le pourcentage
d'individus qui sont impliqués dans des
activités terroristes au canada
et quand même minime je peux vous dire
que le scrs en tête aujourd'hui sur plus
de 200 canadiens dont les activités sont
liées au terrorisme
l'ex directeur du scrs parlait alors de
200 individus liés au terrorisme
c'était en 2010 depuis cette information
est classé top secret la france est plus
transparente et admet être aux prises
avec 15000 personnes fichées pour leur
radicalisation islamique
mais contrairement à la france le canada
ne serait pas infiltrée par des réseaux
organisés selon la grc dur que des
groupes qui sont bien établis ici au
canada
la menace qu'on voit c'est vraiment
celle de loups solitaires des gens qui
sont radicalisées à la violence des gens
qui ont fait partie et qui sont revenus
dans la mire des autorités
les voyageurs à risques ceux qui partent
pour la série ou l'irak dans les 25 et
plus années que je travaille au service
j'ai travaillé surtout dans le domaine
du terrorisme
je vous dis au niveau des nombres
d'individus qui ont voyagé en syrie et
en irak
c'est du jamais vu donc ces individus
qui sont déplacées par la guerre
représente une grosse menace une menace
à long terme
[Musique]
officiellement 6600 occidentaux une
centaine de canadiens se trouvent
actuellement en turquie en syrie et en
irak mais ils sont probablement plus
nombreux je peux pas vous dire que nous
connaissons tous les canadiens qui sont
à l'étranger que participer dans les
acteurs russes ça serait exagéré de ma
mort le chercheur universitaire à marnes
al ahmar à sing and a réussi à
communiquer directement avec les
combattants étrangers en syrie sur les
réseaux sociaux
beaucoup de ce qui est écrit de ce qu'on
connaît de ces individus revient
d'intermédiaire
le but était de leur parler sur une
longue période à mesure que la situation
évolue en irak et en syrie
il a identifié 60 de combattants
canadiens présents en syrie ou en irak
22 de l'ontario 17 de l'alberta 16 du
québec 3 de colombie-britannique 4 de
province d'origine inconnue
canvas unis le canada est unique parce
qu'on voit beaucoup de réseaux d'amis à
calgary ottawa et montréal
des gens partent pour la syrie parce que
quelqu'un qu'il connaisse est parti
avant eux
heureusement la vie que j'étais comme
vous le canadien typique les deux
ontarienne
john may cry et on trie poule comme tous
les canadiens je regarde alors que le
montréalais daniela be phare à celle de
calgary ont fait la propagande du jihad
les groupes terroristes recrute alors
des combattants mais en juin 2014
le message change avec c'est à allah le
très-haut a dit le combat vous a été
prescrit
aboubakar al bagdadi le chef de days
proclame la création de khalifa un état
souverain
régis par la loi islamique la charia
maintenant je crois qu'au plus fort du
mouvement en 2014 2015
l'état islamique tenait ce genre de
propagande nous avons de l'agriculture
des écoles des hôpitaux ici quoi que
vous fassiez vous pouvez faire ici dans
l'année qui suit la création du califat
16 québécois seraient partis pour la
série xiii de montréal et trois de
sherbrooke
wassim boughadou qui fait des allers
retours depuis 2013 comme combattant
part avec sa femme sa belle soeur et
quatre enfants en bas âge
nous avons tenu une lettre écrite par un
autre québécois que nous ne pouvons
identifier et qui se trouve en séries ça
fait déjà presque cinq mois que je suis
parti j'étudie la médecine avec la
meilleure des volontés car j'ai trouvé
un réel but c'est pas juste des jeunes
qui partent c'est des familles entières
des vieux des médecins ingénieurs
avocats etc
et je vois le réel sourire sur leur
visage partir pour la série n'est pas
illégal ce qui était légal c'est de
participer aux activités d'un groupe
classé comme terroriste par le fédéral
même si c'est pour soigner ou enseigner
c'est d'ici que la grc suit la trace de
ceux qui partent de ceux qui reviennent
la police fédéral accepte de nous
dévoiler son centre d'opérations top
secret
ce centre a été créé en 2014 à la suite
des attentats au parlement d'ottawa
depuis l'immigration les douanes
le scrs et la grc et des partenaires à
l'étranger partagent leurs informations
souvent reçoit d'information des
familles qui nous disent on croit que
notre fils une fille sont en train de se
préparer pour voyager en turquie en
syrie pour rejoindre neige et dans ces
cas là ça nous permet justement de cours
donnés très rapidement de les terminer
où sont ils est-ce qu'ils sont déjà en
europe est-ce qu'ils sont à lumière sur
qui on travaille de très près aussi avec
la police nationale la turquie qui nous
permet d'intervenir avant qu'ils
puissent faire de très jeunes en syrie
et les retourner vers le canada c'est ce
qui est arrivé aux montréalais mais juan
gagny en 2013 il est à la frontière
entre la turquie et la syrie
quand la police turque lui met la main
au collet dans un document déposé en
cour la grc soutient que me roy n'a
tenté de se rendre en séries à une autre
occasion
cette fois avec daniel mintal darko
selon les allégations il allait
rejoindre son ami d'enfance amis et
labit partis combattre en syrie pour
java talent ni sera
signaler aux autorités turques les deux
montréalais sont refoulés à la frontière
et rapatrié au canada dans cet affidavit
merouane aurait déclaré un bon musulman
a des responsabilités d'aider ses frères
de n'importe quelle façon possible avec
des armes si ça doit se faire
la meilleure mort c'est la mort du
martyr à wingles les séduire par la
propagande de pêche en quelques mois et
se radicalise sur internet
sandrine je pouvais entendre travers la
porte de sa chambre mais vidéo de
radicalisation qu'il regardait je savais
que ce n'était pas bon et je les
confronter il m'a répondu qu'il ne
faisait de mal à personne et que je
devais me mêler des affaires de la
proximité qu'ils avaient en ligne avec
ces individus a eu un impact important
pour lui parce qu'il n'y avait personne
autour de lui il n'avait pas d'amis
proches
il a eu une enfance difficile alors la
communauté qui l'a trouvé en ligne a
pris une place importante dans sa vie
ce qui inquiète la police ce sont ces
échanges en ligne avec déjà 10 connu
entre autre avec elton simpson cet
américain accompagné d'un complice prend
d'assaut le centre où se tient un
concours de caricatures de mahomet en
mai 2015
selon la grc quelques heures avant
l'attentât
il a écrit un canadien ahren driver son
père s'est rendu compte de la gravité de
la situation
quand le scrs est venu frapper à sa
porte
l'agent m'a montré les messages twitter
et facebook qu'il partageait qui disait
que des gens mérite est d'être tué que
c'était leur faute
il s'est réjoui de certains s'attendent
à assise au café j'ai pleuré
le 4 juin 2015
air india veut est arrêté la grc n'a pas
assez de preuves pour l'accusé même s'il
s'affiche comme un membre de dèche
rien ne prouve selon la police fédérale
qu'il a l'intention de commettre un
crime
irene doit s'engager à garder la paix le
tribunal lui ordonne de porter un
bracelet de sécurité muni d'un gps
c'est à ce moment qu'il donne une
entrevue à la radio pour convaincre
qu'il n'est pas dangereux
[Musique]
en tant qu'expert de la radicalisation
violente
amarna tamara singhane est mandaté par
l'avocat darwin pour évaluer son degré
de dangerosité
so i spoke to one time nous lui avons
parlé pendant un bon moment
il appuyait évidemment l'état islamique
il ne se gênait pas pour le dire et
militer pour le califat mais nous sommes
arrivés à la conclusion qu'il ne
représentait pas une menace parce que
rennes avait une vision nuancée de la
violence selon lui on ne doit pas tuer
des gens innocents mais si une personne
commet un acte contre l'islam alors la
violence ou une certaine forme de
violence est justifié l'évaluation
convainc le tribunal car elles doivent
eux n'est pas si dangereux on lui retire
son bracelet de sécurité et lui interdit
de se procurer un passeport
rappelons nous que martin couture
rouleau et m'a causé habib aux deux
autres convertis à l'islam
ce sont eux aussi fait saisir leurs
passeports par la grc
empêcher quelqu'un de partir peut
représenter un danger selon l'ancien
analyste du scrs phil goss qui j'imagine
qu'ils se sont dit j'aimerais être
martillac le moudjahed être un héros en
syrie mais j'ai pas ce choix maintenant
à cause de vous alors je vais faire ici
il ya une catégorie d'individus qui
peuvent être frustrés de ne pas pouvoir
voyager pour participer à un acte
terroriste
donc ils peuvent chercher à le faire en
sol canadien
c'est une réalité on est conscient de
cette réalité dans ces camps là on
devrait les suivre de très près pour
assurer qu'ils n'achètent pas des armes
à feu qu'ils elles qui construisent pas
des bombes
peut-être ces cas là il faut que les
conditions soient sully à eux doivent
eux s'engagent à respecter aux
conditions dont l'interdiction d'aller
sur les médias sociaux
il habite chez sa soeur astra trop et en
ontario
une petite municipalité rurale de 20000
habitants et wind se rapporte à la
police toutes les deux semaines
il va au jim et travaillent dans cette
usine de pièces automobiles
en apparence il mène une petite vie
tranquille et semble respecter ces
conditions à ce temps là ils ont pris la
décision qu'ils ne céderont n'était pas
le numéro un en adossant requins on a
d'autres personnes qu'on sait qu'ils
étaient là dessus
en avril dernier irene a écrit un texto
à hamar nat
je vais bien grâce à dieu le temps est
beau j'ai beaucoup d'amis il travaille
va bien je suis toujours occupé ce qui
est bien je n'aime pas perdre mon temps
à mornac ne recevra plus d'autres
messages darwin
trois mois plus tard dix jours avant de
mettre à exécution son projet meurtrier
des bruits suspects attire l'attention
des voisins
les voisins préviennent la police les
agents se rendent sur place
en sachant que l'homme qui habite cette
maison est sur le radar de la grc pour
ses activités liées au terrorisme
les policiers croient qu'il s'agit de
feux d'artifices et ne juge pas
pertinent de demander un mandat de
perquisition
il n'y a pas de surveillance attentive
de toute évidence il a été capable
d'apprendre comment fabriquer une bombe
d'acheter ce qu'il fallait de la
fabriquer dans sa cour arrière sans que
personne ne s'en aperçoive
alors qu'il s'était engagé à garder la
paix non seulement qu'on a besoin des
conditions qui recadre l'individu de
respecter et de garder la paix on doit
avoir des conditions qui permet la
police d'état mesure d'aller vérifier si
les 18 du respecte les conditions la grc
voudrait suivre de plus près ce qui
s'engage à garder la paix dans les
dossiers liés au terrorisme
elle veut pouvoir intervenir plus
rapidement ce que la loi ne lui permet
pas actuellement
le ministre fédéral de la sécurité
publique reconnaît qu'il faut tirer des
leçons de la sphère de wever
le gouvernement fédéral attend dès la
fin des audiences publiques sur la
sécurité nationale qui viennent de se
terminer pour apporter des changements
erwin prend régulièrement un taxi pour
se rendre à la mosquée de london à 35 km
de chez lui irene l'ignorent mais les
leaders de la mosquée sont en contact
avec la grc
nous ne sommes pas une agence de police
ou d'évaluation on s'assurerait plutôt
de l'appliquer de favoriser les échanges
de le rapprocher de la communauté des
membres de la mosquée ont tenté de lui
enseigner les vraies valeurs de l'islam
à plusieurs occasions des gens lui ont
parlé du message de la vraie nature de
l'islam et lui ont dit que les visions
radical qu'il pouvait mener à des
injustices ou à toute forme de violence
étaient totalement inacceptables et
concluant
erin est fermé à ce genre de discours
il n'est pas prêt à remettre en question
ses idées radicales mais bien
j'espère que ça va répondre à vos
attentes et en tout cas que ça va pas
trahir le message que vous le bédéiste
el diablo a eu plusieurs échanges avec
des jeunes du centre de prévention de la
radicalisation menant à la violence de
montréal aujourd'hui et leur présentent
leurs oeuvres collectives radical y show
ces jeunes montréalais ont tous tenté de
partir pour la série aucun et accusé
certains font toujours l'objet d'une
enquête
ils ont refusé d'être identifié il ya
des mots que je pouvais pas employé par
exemple on méritait de dire jihadistes
et puis on voulait pas focaliser sur ces
choses là forcément
donc moi j'ai décalé le truc avec céline
jedi et si les djihadistes sont des jedi
de la guerre des étoiles
dans cette quête de nouveaux mondes la
syrie devient ta touline ce sont des
enfants
ce sont des adolescents ces cent des
enfants qui ont pris des décisions naïf
de bonne foi à l'époque qu'il pense être
en conséquence le centre de prévention
est d'abord un centre de signalements en
un an et demi il a reçu 80 deux appels
fondé liée à la radicalisation politico
religieuse
le centre a référé à la grc tous cas
jugés trop lourds c'est à la fois des
gens dont nous avons des indices qu'il y
avait une dangerosité de radicalisation
soit d'inquiétude de soi de passage à
l'acte qui était qui nous inquiétait de
radicalisation à destrem où on avait des
gens qui étaient prêts par an pas partir
je prends un exemple un parent qu'il me
qui nous appellent qui médisent écoutez
j'ai découvert ça chez mon fils ici lol
et haga d'internet et là il a faim
demande de 2,2
harmonie eu et j'ai vu de passeport il a
l'intention de partir il demande au
centre par exemple de annulé son
passeport
j'ai pas nos pouvoirs au sein de
supprimer son passeport et là on va dire
aux parents de nouvelles valeurs
informer les autres policiers qu'ils
sont compétents travailleurs sociaux et
psychothérapeute travaillent étroitement
auprès de 17 jeunes radicaliser dont les
huit étudiants du cégep de maisonneuve
intercepté à l'aéroport en mai 2015
après un an et demi d'existence et un
bassin d'extrémistes relativement petit
le centre s'est néanmoins gagné une
réputation mondiale il a participé à
l'organisation de la conférence
internationale sur la radicalisation
avec l'unesco
le secrétaire général de l'onu mais
aussi des délégations de france et de
belgique sont venus en visite le
directeur et des membres de son équipe
se sont rendus dans neuf pays dont
singapour
l'algérie et la tunisie pour expliquer
le modèle québécois la crédulité
aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est le fait que
nous avons une stratégie de prise en
charge de personnes radicaliser qui
n'est pas seulement une prise en charge
clinique mais qui est autre chose
d'intervention communauté à qui la
réinsertion
c'est ça la crédibilité des options que
personnel c'est ailleurs que nous
essayons québec mais est ce que c'est un
succès non attention on va attendre un
truc tu parce que les expériences au
niveau international en matière de
réinsertion sont encore tout neuf il
faut attendre contre 5 ans minimum
pouvoir excuse les prises en charge on a
fait ça fonctionne ou pas donc on va se
donner le temps
les prises en charge se font sur une
base volontaire les cas plus menaçants
ne sont donc pas ici
la majorité des jeunes suivis d avoir
voulu se rendre en séries pour faire du
travail humanitaire
est ce que il ya eu un discours en
disant qu'on va passer à l'acte au
québec au canada
moi j'ai pas entendu et ce sens ils nous
diront pas mais c'est sûr et certain
mais je vais te naïf en disant que j'ai
jamais écouté ça j'ai jamais eu cette
perception d'un le directeur du centre
de prévention a tenté de joindre en
prison deux autres jeunes montréalais
sabrine german et elle m'a dit jamie lee
ils sont accusés d'avoir voulu
participer à des activités terroristes
en série et d'avoir possédé du matériel
explosif
on avait demandé on en a fait des
démarches auprès d'eads a coulé pour les
rencontrer pour pour proposer le service
du centre
on n'a pas eu de retour comme je ne peux
pas obliger ces volontaires généralement
c'est qu'en fait ces qualifs ce qu'ont
les gens ne nous approchent pas nous ont
fait la démarche contraire nous ré les
approcher merouane galmi n'a jamais été
accusé après avoir accepté de porter un
bracelet de sécurité pendant un an il a
retrouvé sa pleine liberté ce que vous
avez approché mais juan galmi celui le
cas porter un bracelet de sécurité
pendant un homme mais qui est
aujourd'hui en liberté
pas du tout parce qu'on a pas de contact
pour approcher quelqu'un il faut savoir
où on n'est pas la police doivent à leur
adresse donc c'est difficile ici
viennent pas nous ce qu'on connaît tous
ce qu'on connaisse alors à son contact
avoir avoir tout ce qu'il faut dans son
ne connaît pas c'est difficile pour eux
j'ai perdu mon fils à l'âge de 19 ans en
trois mois et demi de présence en syrie
après la mort de son fils
salia ben ali a créé un comité de
parents en belgique
des parents qui partagent la même
souffrance le départ de leurs enfants
pour la série quand on se renferme sur
soi on se replie la souffrance elle sait
pas sortir et l'encouragent les parents
montréalais à sortir de l'ombre et à se
regrouper
vous n'êtes pas obligé de tous visibles
et si vous avez un groupe de parents un
avocat qui peut vous représentez haut
niveau donc juridique international
c'est déjà votre force
ce soir là dans un restaurant chinois de
montréal
une douzaine de parents sont présents
cinq seulement acceptent d'être filmés
de dos leurs enfants ont tenté de se
rendre en syrie
d'autres ont réussi et sont encore
là-bas la relève québécoise comme mc
plusieurs polémiques pendant des années
plusieurs des marques sur ça et cette
jeunesse a vécu à l'âge du primaire du
secondaire avec des débats et de la pac
dans tout ce qu'ils font du ski félin
d'identité quand tu n'as pas été pris
moi ma personne j'étais juste diriger
l'un j'étais hors de moi je ne suis allé
j'avais aucune ressource heures en ma
possession leurs enfants se
connaissaient pour la plupart ceux qui
sont partis en janvier 2015 aurait
inspiré les autres les jeunes que nous
ont paru cité des modèles de modèles les
ai juste la bande dessinée delvaille de
les veinards sont parties en russie donc
c'était quand même modèle d glorifiant
ils ont réussi à atteindre leurs
objectifs sont réussis à partie entre
les filets donc au micro cutter en
disant que tout va bien on envoie des
belles photos on associe en vie dans des
châteaux ça se passe bien
dans sa lettre le montréalais que nous
pouvons identifier qui se trouve
présentement en syrie et convaincus
d'assister à un tournant de l'histoire
par la volonté d'allah ici on voit les
vrais hommes combattre ils peuvent être
inférieurs en nombre mais ils vont avoir
la victoire avec l'aide d'allah c'est
une prophétie qui ce réalisme vous
pouvez me prendre pour un fou
vous verrez les écrits sont en train de
se réaliser
21 des dix canadiens ont plutôt trouvé
la mort 8 alberta 9 ontarienne quatre
québécois mais il ya des survivants
selon le scrs 60 canadiens sont de
retour ils ne reviennent pas tous de
syrie ou d'irak
mais d'autres zones de combat comme la
somalie l'afghanistan ou la libye les
parents que nous avons rencontrés ils
sont inquiets
quel sera le sort de leurs enfants à
leur retour ils sont convaincus que
leurs enfants ne participent pas aux
combats la plupart disent on ne rien au
fait que confirmer sociaux dont le ce
point au point plusieurs de ses parents
sont en contact presque quotidien avec
leurs enfants en syrie qui leur disent
peu de choses sur ce qui se passe là bas
les montréalais seraient toujours
ensemble deux des leurs seraient morts
et certains ont eu des bébés
ces enfants sont la série ils ont de
quelle nationalité n'ont pas la clé part
et c'est comment on fait avec ses
enfants
j'avais un passeport canadien c'est quoi
la démarche
le fonds doit avoir une politique des
retours on a une solution est ce qu'on
les accueille qu'elle le soutient qu'on
leur donne que le chou peur qu'on leur
donne ce qui est sûr et certain
l'option prison n'est pas approprié pour
tout le monde il faut évaluer au cas par
cas
s'assure que chaque personnel de soutien
psychosocial nécessaires pour que ces
personnes soient réintégrés dans leur
intérêt dans la société des individus
qui reviennent de saison sont une grande
priorité pas de service parce qu'il faut
évaluer
est ce qui revient pour une mission est
ce qu'il revienne pour faire un attentat
au canada où est-ce qu'ils reviennent
parce que il ne veut plus rien savoir du
côté russe ça l'est aussi
ces gens là le retour on voit
certainement les interviewés savoir
quelles sont leurs intentions ou ce
qu'ils ont des moeurs x qui cherche à
faire c'est certain que nous allons
porter une attention ses jambes
à moins qu'il ne s'affichent comme des
combattants dans les publications de
dèche
il est très difficile de les accuser
c'est extrêmement difficile de
recueillir la preuve nécessaire parce
que nous avons pas une bonne couverture
des activités qui se passe en syrie en
erreur parmi ceux qui sont revenus au
canada aucun est en prison
aucune accusation n'a été portée contre
eux le 18 décembre 2015
ce montréalais se prenaient en négo
portrait avec le premier ministre justin
trudeau
il fait pourtant l'objet d'une enquête
la grc le soupçonnent d'avoir pris part
à une prise d'otages de deux américains
en syrie pour jab à tanus sera est ce
qu'ils peuvent vraiment surveiller tue
ceux qui reviennent
épreuve phare on me dit par exemple pour
le gers et de suivre quelqu'un
physiquement et d'avoir tout l'été le
grec quitte à l'éducation etc
chaque personne il faut au moins 40
personnes pour aller y tient un individu
de 40 personnes
les autorités policières avouent leur
incapacité à suivre tous ceux qui
reviennent
la situation ne va pas s'améliorer
depuis octobre dernier
les combats font rage en irak et en
syrie pour libérer les villages et les
villes occupées bardèche le scrs
s'attend à ce que plusieurs canadiens
reviennent
après la pause la grc fait le pari de la
prévention peut-être les gens ils vont
commencer car qu'on est là pour
peut-être les esprits en ligne ou pour
soutirer de l'information et sauber en
route ça soit clair qu'on est là géré au
niveau de la sensibilisation
le commissaire adjoint james manistes ya
établi les priorités de la grc et décide
qui est surveillé qui ne l'est pas si
vous voyez une photo de mon grappin et
kohler il prend ses décisions en se
rappelant son grand père aux petites
heures du matin et mon grand père avait
été arrêté un fait le gers est arrivé à
la maison et ils ont la sortie tous les
enfants inclus à ma mère en 1940 son
grand-père a été interné pendant trois
ans parce qu'ils étaient soupçonnés
d'être fasciste le feu que le 31 mai
l'italo canadien avait été déclarée
étrangers ennemis et plus de 600
ensuite emprisonné sans procès et une
leçon que nous devons jamais oublier
il nous devons faire attention que nous
apporte donc des questions de sécurité
nationale pour s'assurer que nous allons
pas criminaliser une communauté comme
cet effet par le passé
la lutte contre le terrorisme évolué
l'ennemi change les stratégies pour y
faire face aussi depuis les attentats de
paris
le canada a misé beaucoup sur la
prévention
un dimanche après midi d'été dans une
fête communautaire du quartier saint
michel à montréal
la grc veut gagner la confiance de la
population particulièrement de la part
des immigrants qui arrivent de pays
totalitaire où la police est corrompue
peut-être les gens ils vont penser quand
on est là pour peut-être pour les
esprits en les courses ou terry de la
foire
et ça on devra
on veut que ça soit clair qu'on est là
c'est au niveau
la grc enseigne à tous les corps de
police du pays à détecter les signaux de
radicalisation il n'y a pas de recette
miracle
c'est pas parce qu'on a t'elle facteurs
que la personne va se radicaliser
c'est pas parce que ce plan fonctionne
pour désengager une personne il va
fonctionner pour tous les personnes dans
chaque cas est unique
la grc ne peut pas surveiller tout le
monde il ya donc besoin d'antenne des
compagnies liées aux secteurs de
l'énergie des transports et des banques
apprennent à reconnaître les indices
d'attentats ce sont des secteurs
névralgiques qui peuvent être la cible
de terroristes
vous connaissez votre infrastructure
votre domaine votre environnement votre
carré de ça plus facile pour vous de
détecter des signes étranges
c'est ça le système de signalement des
incidents suspecte le scrs et la grc le
répète lutter contre le terrorisme
c'est la sphère du tout le monde
le plus important complot terroriste au
canada celui des 18 de toronto a été
déjouée grâce à la filature de la police
et la dénonciation de mohamed web est un
leader religieux doivent eux a été
dénoncé à la police par des leaders
musulmans sous surveillance policière
pendant 18 mois
et pourtant je suis resté sans voir
souffler j'étais au volant de mon auto
quand un ami journaliste m'a demandé si
je suivais ce qui se passait a trahi je
lui dis que non il n'y avait qu'une
seule personne astra troy qui pouvait
correspondre
j'espérais que ce ne soit pas lui ils
étaient sous surveillance depuis si
longtemps
ça ne pouvait pas être lui en voyant
cette vidéo à la télé il reconnaît à win
à ses yeux j'étais atterré c'était
incroyable cette vidéo testament à
d'abord été remarqué par le fbi qui a
aussitôt reconnus l'accent canadien est
prévenu la grc
irene l'avait envoyé à un individu que
le fbi à surveiller il sera le 10 août
dernier
il manque dans un taxi avec deux bombes
sur lui
il demande au chauffeur de le conduire
au centre commercial seti plaza à
l'homme
si on se fie à son propre témoignage il
allait peut-être se faire exploser à ce
centre de recrutement de l'armée
encerclé par des policiers alors qu'il
s'apprête à partir en taxi à rennes
déclenché la bombe qu'il portait sur lui
sans grands dégâts
il est abattu devant chez lui par un
agent de la grc
je crois que l'impact de l'ordonance de
garder la paix a été très différent sur
et rennes comparativement à quelqu'un
d'autre se passerait pour certains ça ne
fonctionne pas c'est encore plus vrai si
la personne n'est pas bien entouré n'a
pas de soutien émotif et social c'est
malheureusement ce qui est arrivé à et
ron même au moment où ce qu'on croit que
certains individus peu justement est sur
une bonne voie
on n'est pas à l'intérieur de leur tête
alors il devient difficile de savoir
parfois à quel moment qu'ils vont
justement passé de l'éradication à la
violence aux indicateurs de mobilisation
adopté depuis l'adoption de la loi
antiterroriste en 2001 vingt-trois
personnes ont été reconnues coupables de
terrorisme dans onze lié à un seul
attentat celui de toronto
neuf autres sont en attente de procès et
deux portent des bracelets de sécurité
je pense pas qu'on a besoin de vivre
qu'une certaine et sécurité la mana soit
toujours évolué elle évolué depuis les
trous quatre dernières années depuis les
dix dernières années elle va continuer à
évoluer
nous devons s'adapter je dis toujours
que cette menace se rassurer en moins
une dizaine d'années et peut-être
jusqu'à 1,5 à danané
parce que l'idéologie ça va durer et
comment celle ci serait la réponse
championnat depuis l'offensive de la
coalition et les pertes de dèche sur les
territoires irakiens et syriens
les canadiens sont moins nombreux à
partir mais des ge continue son règne de
terreur en multipliant les attaques
sanglantes
[Musique]